2020 has been like no other year we've
ridden the wave
through 2020 and i wanted to bring to
you 10 lessons
that we've learned here at think if
you're just joining us for the first
time my name
is heather torres and i am the host of
the think
marketing podcast i want to welcome you
if you're new to the podcast and let you
know that we release an episode
every single tuesday and i'd love to
encourage you to share this
with a friend if you are getting value
out of these lessons or
any other episode maybe send a friend a
text or
send them a dm on instagram all about
this
podcast it would mean the world to us if
you would share this with the other
leaders and the other people in your
life
who are wanting to grow a youtube
channel or build an online
business now we are heading into a
two-part series
sharing with you at the end of the year
and at the beginning of the year
some lessons that we've learned in 2020.
we can all agree that 2020
has been like no other year and i'm
excited because in this first
two episodes sean is sharing with you
the 10 lessons that
he's learned this one he'll share five
and the next one he'll share
five additional and what i think is
going to be maybe eye eye-opening
is during this episode he really dives
into
being vulnerable he really shares some
numbers and stats
that might be surprising to you where we
started
when all of this in 2020 happened i
think it's really great to be able to
share your successes online and share
that with your community
but i also think that a lot of times
people can more so relate to
the struggles that you feel and so the
five lessons that sean shares in this
episode i think will be eye opening and
really give you an
insight into how we think here at
think so i'm excited let's get into
today's talk
[Music]
wow 2020 was a crazy year and i'm
excited to talk about
in this two-part series 10 lessons total
five lessons in this episode that 2020
taught me that i actually believe will
really serve you
even going into 2021 and beyond
and let's get right into it number one
crisis
reveals character 2020 really taught me
that crisis reveals character
now james lane allen said this quote
adversity doesn't build
character it reveals it and i think 2020
really showed us that you know
when we think about the fact that hard
times can teach us things i think that
is true
but really more than anything hard times
and crisis
actually reveals our character it's not
really until you get squeezed that you
see
what's really inside of you and 2020
was been a hard year for a lot of people
and i understand that sometimes
depending we've all been given different
circumstances so under the weight of
maybe
job loss or if you owned a brick and
mortar store or a restaurant or
something
there's so many different dimensions of
how 2020 could hit you but i think we
had a chance this year
to either get bitter through everything
that was happening through the pandemic
and through an election and through
everything else
or to choose to get better and really i
recognized
and saw a lot of friends peers fellow
business owners other people
that in the midst of the crisis some
their character really came to the
surface i mean people's
maybe you notice this whether it's at
the grocery store whether somebody else
people are on edge
like who they really are started to
really come out that's definitely a
lesson that i learned
you know it also makes me think of you
know people say money changes people
i actually don't believe that money
doesn't change people it amplifies
who they already are money is a turbo
charger for maybe what's already inside
of you and so that is a huge lesson 2020
taught me number two
crisis reveals opportunities
you know with financial crisis racial
tensions and racial injustice media
elections
there was a lot of really challenging
things this year and even going
into 2021 there are pretty much still
the same challenges a lot of things
still lingering and
i never want to be insensitive to
the real harsh realities
that the pandemic and things like that
have triggered because it's not like
it's just you know delusional optimism
however crisis does reveal opportunities
and there is a quote that says
opportunity often comes disguised
in the form of misfortune or temporary
defeat napoleon hill said that and that
every adversity
every failure every heartbreak carries
within it a seed of equal or greater
benefit wow that every adversity
everything that we went through in 2020
every heartbreak
break inside of it is a seed of equal or
greater benefit
and so 2020 really gave us the
opportunity to
see what is the silver lining if you
will
in what's happening with um the pandemic
and things like that
and i would acknowledge we are blessed
at think media think marketing
because we were already in a future
industry if you will
that everyone started to need you know
it's almost like we've been learning to
swim for the last 10 years
not realizing that the world was gonna
get flooded and
all of a sudden people need live
streaming how do i zoom what webcam do i
need so
the opportunities really bubbled to the
surface for especially think media
and actually really amplified our
business but here's the thing
we're helping you build your influence
with video more than ever before
there is a spotlight and an opportunity
to work from home to create content from
home to master youtube to master online
business
to go into e-commerce uh which brings us
to number three of lessons i learned
this year is that the future is coming
faster
and when i think about opportunities
that this crisis revealed
it actually sped up certain industries
and is bringing the future faster to us
what do i mean things like online in
general more people are leaning in on
the internet more people are looking
towards the internet online video
it's growing i remember back in march of
2020
we help a lot of people entrepreneurs
business owners people in real estate
network marketing personal finance all
kinds of different industries
we also help a lot of people in ministry
and a pastor
um joined our video ranking academy
program hired me for coaching and we
ended up because he also was
had a leadership kind of arm of things
he was writing a book and doing a few
other things
and he said you know i'm going to be
honest with you sean i didn't even
think about youtube until i could no
longer meet in person in my church
and part of me was like well you're in
the right place here to help like how
can we help you how can we serve you
the other part of me was shocked i was
like it's
march at this time 2020 and you haven't
thought about youtube yet but then i
also
kind of remembered that look it's not
like everybody eats sleeps
drinks breathes and lives youtube the
way that i do or the way that maybe even
you do in our community does
the future's coming faster and now more
people are shopping online
watching content online studies revealed
that adult social media consumption
doubled during the pandemic
and it's not like it's gonna it will of
course recede a little bit but it's not
gonna go back
entirely because people are forming new
habits
they're learning new skill sets my mom
did not know how to watch
instagram stories and then i had a son
sean bradley kennel and now she is an
instagram stories junkie but she always
tells me sean
they disappear i don't know why they
they disappear i'm like you can just
rewatch the whole story mom just click
back
well no i only get like i only get the
three seconds to look at the picture
that it's gone and i'm like mom
listen so you get it people are moving
online they're learning new skills
the future is coming faster another
report revealed
amazon's breaking record sales all year
long and that e-commerce growth
which just means online shopping has
accelerated
to the projected numbers of 2022.
what yeah because of the lockdown
because of the pandemic
the future's coming faster what was
expected to be the adoption of shopping
online
and that we wouldn't hit those numbers i
think bigger than 20
2 out of 10 people starting to really
shop online
by 2022 is now happening today and won't
change
because people are like oh this is cool
oh i like having things auto delivered
i like shopping online i see that i
could order something with
free shipping free returns try it on and
send back the one that didn't fit
i'm learning a whole new skill set what
does that mean for you
and for me it means that there's really
never been a better time to lean into
creating content
to affiliate marketing to thinking about
how you can
answer specific questions solve problems
the future
is coming faster the internet video
e-commerce
social media all of those this is a
growing industry
it's not going backwards in fact it's
going faster
forward and that's a major lesson 2020
taught me number four the best defense
is a good offense now
you maybe have heard that before famous
phrase
it's actually known as the strategic
offensive principle of war generally
it's the idea that
pro-activity a strong offensive action
instead of a passive attitude will
preoccupy the opposition
and ultimately hinder its ability to
mount an opposing counter-attack
leading to having a strategic advantage
the best defense is a good offense it's
called the strategic
offensive principle and man this
is like the lesson that i think really
hit me personally and hit our team
personally
in 2020 that i think is more critical
than ever before
in 2021 because things haven't changed
much
joan banez said this action is the
antidote to despair now
said with empathy we're living through
the greatest mental health crisis some
people say the world's ever seen
suicide's going up depression is going
up
discouragement is is on all-time rise
and people are in all kinds of different
circumstances they may be well off
financially
but sad or despondent because they can't
see family or they feel isolated
we can't see people's smiles because
they're behind masks
there's so much there's so much division
it feels like here in the america
that the country's never been more
divided there's a lot of despair
well this quote said that action is the
antidote for despair
and what we learned in 2020 was that
while the majority waited
we went to war and i know of that for
some
they were maybe kind of just put into a
level paralysis
a lot of our peers competitors other
people in the industry
people in the bigger maybe personal
development business development
niche all these different things i saw a
lot of people just kind of wait it out
just kind of see like let's ride this
thing out i don't know what's going to
happen
or some that maybe couldn't overcome
that despair
but man the best antidote for despair is
action
and while other people waited we went to
war and you know
one of the benefits that happened at
think media was even
not because of the pandemic just because
we had expanded
hired more people began to invest in
some things to grow the company
going into february of 2020
we were negative 30 000 on our profit
and loss
i don't know how you would feel if you
saw one month that you
were down thirty thousand dollars it's
not very good man you know my wife is
our cfo she's like
this you know math is not your strong
sean but let me just explain this to you
being negative
30 000 in a month is a bad thing
actually when it comes
what you want is you want to be not in
the red but you want to be in the black
right you know even even's good plus 10
would be nice
you want to be positive we were negative
going into february and then i started
seeing the news going into march
and so i was like oh my dear god the
ship is sinking like
i i kind of felt this pressure
before even talking to the think media
team like what are we going to do and i
really had an option
do i shrink back in despair
or do i decide that action is the
antidote to despair
and and do i start playing defense do we
start playing defense or do we
go on offense and we really leaned
into this concept of wartime versus
peacetime leaders
and i felt stirred i mean just praying
and and studying and getting advice and
getting counseling i was like
man i started to study wartime leaders
first first time peacetime leaders and
realized
now it's wartime if we're if we're
hemorrhaging money if we're down
financially
if there's a pandemic externally if the
future is full of uncertainty
what do we do next and we leaned into
being
wartime leaders and i remember we
started to do a couple practical things
we started to take offense we were
locked down we were spending
less time or no time shooting and even
doing recordings like this where
uh we've got like heather and omar and
kyle here and you know we're all working
from home which we normally do but even
more so
and um you know where the situation was
changing we're having like stay-at-home
orders
and so we started to double down
meetings i was like we need to
communicate more with the team we went
to a monday
uh wednesday and friday meeting we we
were doing that just once a week
we started to double down on content we
started to
post more videos we went to five videos
a week we went from uh
three really videos a week two to three
to five
we started multiple shows the think
marketing live show
we did a lot of things and i'll talk
about those in a future lesson
but it really became kind of a wartime
leader
versus a peacetime leader mindset and
i'll cover that
very concept and sort of like the 20
principles of wartime leaders
in a future think marketing podcast
episode but offense
versus defense i want to challenge you
defense matters you got to protect your
ass
sets you got to protect your assets but
offense is the only way you're ever
going to win the game if you don't put
points on the board
and here's a kind of a interesting story
we talked about
throughout the thick media team in
regards to this lesson
was i don't know if you've seen the
movie uh forrest gump
but there's a scene in forrest gump
where they're they're stripping
right there they got their shrimping
company and forest
and lieutenant dan is out on on the ship
in the midst of a storm
and they're on the ship and there's a
crazy storm and i
remember lieutenant dan's like on the
top of the uh you know
the sails and he's like god if you will
let us survive tonight and like rain is
pouring and it looks like they're just
going to get crushed by this storm this
crisis
right and they survived the night
because they were out there they were
riding through the storm they were
pressing through the storm
and if you could picture the scene in
the famous movie forrest gump the next
morning they wake up
and there and or the scene cuts back to
them and they're driving along the shore
and
all the other boats are sidelined
they're all wrecked on the shore washed
up on the
shore because they were out there
because they were leaning in because
they were on
offense they next day they were then the
only ones
there they were like the only ones
standing they're the only ones
you know still out there shrimping and
then they throw down the nets and then
boom
before that they weren't catching any
shrimp but now
crisis came it potentially put a lot of
people
into waiting mode but forest and
lieutenant dan
man they went to war that's what we did
at think media and it's a major lesson
that we learn
we went on offense and what we noticed
was it was a big year
because again we didn't shrink back we
doubled down on content we didn't shrink
back we doubled down on shows and
connection with our community
and started new ways to connect with
people by we started the coffee with
kennel show where i started to answer
people's questions and bring them on
stream yard heather started the think
marketing live show started to bring
people on
we started more shows and started our
video ranking academy and tony does the
vra show
and the tip of the week we started to go
more into community
more into pouring in we we leaned into
offense
and we learned that it actually
accelerated us ahead because while the
majority waited
we went to war this is your opportunity
i think going into 2021
we continue to lean into this and it's a
decision to take leadership
to not be passive right the law of
strategic offensive principle but to
take control
and to take charge and on this lesson i
love how dale carnegie said this
he said inaction breeds doubt and fear
action breeds confidence and courage if
you want to conquer fear
do not sit at home and think about it go
out and get busy
and you might have a stay-at-home order
but you can still get
busy because think about the times we
live in we live in a time
where you can start your show shoot that
video create that channel
build that website start that video
podcast sign up for that affiliate
program
read that book learn that new skill
study like we live
in a chance where if you want to crushed
out and crush fear
you got to crush an action and lean in
and go out
and get busy all right number five
use social media don't let social media
use you you know in 2020
we see this massive opportunity and even
stated at the beginning of this episode
there's more people on social
adults are doubling their social media
use there's more of a chance to reach
people
and impact people with social media but
i believe that social media is a tool
it could be used for good or evil social
media is a tool
it can bring positive things but it
could also bring toxic things
just like money money's not the root of
all evil
the love of money is because money can
in greed can actually
really take hold of your heart and be
toxic but money as a tool
can build orphan edges can free people
from sex trafficking
can build profitable businesses that
impact communities and families
and revive economies and provide
financial freedom to people
it's just a tool social media is just a
tool
and here's my opinion i don't want
tools to use me i want to use the tools
so use social media
don't let social media use you i think
one of the things we saw in 2020 and i
struggled with this
is i think probably a lot of our social
media consumption went up i don't know
if your phone tells you your screen time
every week but i know some weeks it's
like hey
your screen time is up this week and i
recognize that i'm on my phone a lot for
work purposes
but i'm a victim of the scroll as well
endlessly scrolling
comparing my life to others on instagram
come on come just looking for one hit a
dopamine or that or looking for that
next meme that's gonna
help me be distracted from the fears or
the worries that i have that day
i think 2020 taught me the lesson of
just how important it is to guard your
heart and your mind
man when you open up facebook you open
up instagram and and you just see
another
election uh you know headline another
coronavirus headline another this
another that it's just constant when you
think about the news cycle
and drama and politics and
all kinds of stuff it's crazy and you
know when it comes to advertising
statistics revealed that you and me are
exposed
to between 4 000 to 10
000 ads and media messages per day
that is something that god never created
us
to experience in my opinion that is so
much coming at us
so what is the solution
the solution is the fact that unless
you're
tied down with somebody you know
scrolling for you
forcing you to look at your phone it's
up to you to put your phone down
it's up for you to put airplane mode on
it's up to you
to set your phones aside in the drawer
in the box and actually sit down with
your family
across the table and talk to each other
and i'm not trying to stand on the
soapbox
and preach at you i'm saying this is
something i've learned and had to fight
all year long and i think will be a new
skill set that we have to fight
all the way till 2025 and beyond because
we can't let social media
use us we have to use social media
and it made me think about the
importance of you know kind of mental
toughness
and the importance of guarding your
heart guarding your mind
having a clear mind not letting all the
distraction and everybody else's agenda
in your email inbox
everybody else potentially dming you or
or saying this or that on facebook and
all this different stuff that can come
your way my question
is that helping you build your business
and reach your goals is that helping you
stay on offense and protect your heart
and your spirit and your mind so you can
build that business for your family
so that you can impact the people that
need your message so that you can
shoot that video that people need to see
you
educating or entertaining on youtube you
have to be careful
and make sure that social media isn't
using you because that my friends i
think we could all agree
could sometimes lead us to the despair
we feel
instead of the motivation and wholeness
and uh
and energy and health that we want to
feel
so those are just five lessons that 2020
taught me i'm excited for part two so
definitely make sure to check out part
two as well i've got five more
and these ones are more granular and
specific that i believe are going to
help you really crush it and get
momentum
going into 2021 so i can't wait to see
you
in the next next episode
well that was the first five lessons
that sean learned in 2020 and in the
next
episode we're gonna get into five more
really great lessons
that he learned and if you want to go
deeper on
youtube that's what we do here at think
on the think marketing podcast
if you want to go deeper into that well
this episode was actually brought to you
by the think
master class this is our one hour class
for you to learn the
three secrets to success on youtube sean
breaks down
his journey on youtube but not just that
the latest stats and what's actually
working
right now on the platform so if you're
in a position where you want to grow a
youtube channel
maybe you're a business owner or an
entrepreneur who already has a
successfully running business and you
want to learn how do i
bolt on youtube into my marketing
strategy or
maybe you're working a full-time job
right now or you're a stay-at-home mom
and you want to figure out a way to
create additional income for your family
or change careers and go full time on
youtube
this is the class for you and if you've
not yet taken it i want to get you over
to the class because it's brand new
and it's only up for a limited time so
go to
thinkmasterclass.com to check out the
latest class
here at think and i want to thank you if
you've rate or reviewed
this podcast over on apple itunes this
is a great way for
apple itunes to help put our podcast in
front of other people just like you so
today's review comes from hey k jen
and she says such great value is
everything
that the think media think marketing
team does
loved the email marketing episode hey
kjen thank you so much for
leaving that review and letting us know
that that was the episode that impacted
you
it means so much to us to be able to
read your comments and read your reviews
and so
if you haven't yet gone over to itunes
if you're driving right now
just do it when you stop but if you are
on your phone right this minute
i want to ask you to go over there and
rate and review
the podcast and maybe your review will
end up on a future episode well
we are going to conclude today's episode
and we are heading into
part two of this next week i also want
to say
happy new year and excited for the
future and all things that are going to
be happening in 2021.
if 2020 taught us anything it taught us
that
we should be expecting for great things
and that you never
know what's to come so i'll see you in
next year in the next
[Music]
episode
you